did you see tom cruise's meltdown a new
one
oh this is off hot off the presses new
tom cruise meltdown i'm
feeling this so he goes ballistic on
this they're filming motion impossible
seven and there's apparently some sort
of
protocol that's not the name of the
movie it's not mission or possible
seventh
quarter that's actually kind of cool
yeah
mission impossible seven good protocol
uh this is him getting mad because i
guess somebody on the set broke the
protocol here you go
you're back here in hollywood making
movies right now because of
us because they believe in us and what
we're doing
what they believe in
uh they who's they first off and they
believe in us and what we're
you're back in hollywood right now
making movies because they believe in us
and what we're doing
you're not that important all the men
this
this shows you the mentality of these
[ __ ] doesn't it this
shows you their mentality of how
important they think they are
well they are they they give us
entertainment right they're gods sorry
let's keep going
we are the gold standard oh my god we're
back here in hollywood making movies
right now because of
us because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every studio at
night
insurance companies producers
well you're not your lawyer is i don't
think tom cruise is on the phone
yeah seriously let's stop pretending
calm down
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
i think he said you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the rhythm i heard i could be
wrong could be [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone anyone on this crew does it
that's it and you too and you too
and you if you ever do it again
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education tom
cruise expresses frustration there's
more but play a little more but tom
cruise expressed his frustration
with his crew members on the set of
mission impossible seven after he saw
them breaking
teen guidelines two sources close to
production confirmed the variety
as first reported by the sun after crews
saw two crew members standing
do you know what they did what did they
do they were they were standing through
close obviously right
tom cruise saw two crew members standing
too close to one another in front of a
computer screen
well yeah so clearly they needed to to
get it if i see you do it again you're
[ __ ] gone
so wait a second this was two crew
members that were just standing next to
each other by
by the probably editing and looking over
each other which makes sense right
and an audio obtained by the sun crews
can be heard saying where are the cults
okay well let's look at play we have the
idea
um they were standing too close to each
other
buy a computer
no apologies you can tell it to the
people that are losing their
own because our industry is shut down
it's not going to put food on their
table or pay for their college education
that's what i sleep with every night
it must be really difficult being tom
cruise well that and a bunch of you know
probably hot you know junior level
scientologist women but yeah i mean sure
the other thing too
the future
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you and now i want it and if
you don't do it you're out
we are not shutting this movie down
is it understood if i see it again
you're
going and sure you so you're gonna cost
him his job
and i see on the set you're going and
you're going
but weren't you just crying about how
people are going to lose their
livelihoods
and all the working below the line
people in hollywood because they were
standing next to each other are they
going to
pay for their education you just said
that right
that's it am i clear do you
understand what i want you understand
the responsibility that you have
because it's funny that you have to look
down at him while he's yelling at you
it said it's actually true though
a little bit but don't worry george
george clooney weighs in on tom cruise
shouting over
guidelines i understand why he did it of
course he says he understands why tom
cruise lashes out against crew members
on the set of mission impossible in the
two-minute recording posted by the sun
on tuesday
while promoting his newfound midnight
sky clooney 59 said in an interview with
howard stern
that he doesn't think cruz 58 acted
inappropriately so
if you're at a regular job doesn't
matter which question i have
if you're working at a corporate job and
you take your mask off for a second
your boss is allowed to scream at you
and break you like this that's fine that
wouldn't be hr
that wouldn't be an issue she worked at
a regular job and footage came out of
any boss doing that
that man would be fired immediately
right but it's okay because the industry
is important
uh clooney says he didn't overreact
because it is a problem cooney told
stern in reaction to the leak clip
according to news
i have a friend oh here we go i have a
friend who's an ad on another
show who just had the almost exact same
thing happen with not quite
as far of a response however clooney
said that
he had the same thing happen on his set
he would have reacted a bit differently
i wouldn't have done done it that big i
would have have you know pulled the
people out
clooney says you're in a position of
power it's tricky right you ought do
you have to you do have a responsibility
for everybody else
and he's absolutely right about that and
you know if the production goes
down a lot of people lose their jobs
people have to understand that and have
to be responsible it's not just my style
to you know take
everybody to task the way he did they
think
they're this important but can i just
can i just point out that sorry how that
could have been handled
you go hey you guys come over here for a
sec hey everyone come around here for a
second
hey listen i'm not trying to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] here or anything
but like we got a big set this is a big
job everybody from catering to the you
know key grips to the production
assistant
a lot of people uh need this movie to
make a living
nobody else out there is making a living
right now i really need you guys
to be better about this all right you
were over there [ __ ] around you know
your masks on
god forbid some tmz [ __ ] comes in
here and [ __ ] sees that
we're [ __ ] we're absolutely [ __ ]
they'll shut us down
they're probably filming in toronto
right i don't know probably canadian
people are probably gonna shut us
let's not [ __ ] around here please just
try to tighten up i don't really want to
have to keep telling you guys
just do that for me please so we don't
have to we have one less thing to worry
about
you see how easy that was you could take
me saying that
and nobody would go wow he's a lunatic
you just go like
guys seriously like there's a way to
pull everyone in and go please don't do
what they just did or we're [ __ ]
that's he this that is that entitled
i'm the king of scientology and i'm the
king of hollywood since the 80s and you
better
[ __ ] do what i say or i will [ __ ]
lose my mind on you
i'm starting to think that in tropic
thunder old tommy boy wasn't playing les
grossman
i have a feeling that tom cruise was
just playing the other side of tom
cruise
the amount of lefties that are right now
and i'm reading it are defending this is
blows my mind so this is from the slate
right
i begrudgingly admit that tom cruise is
right tom cruise lost his mind on the
set of mission impossible seven after
spotted two of the crew standing less
than a meter away from each other
according to british tabloid the sun in
an audio we always know what he says the
blow up is unsettling mostly because
it's a rich powerful man yelling curse
words of people who work for him
it's additionally unsettling because
it's this particular rich man tom cruise
has allegedly cursed out underlings at
least once before
and in a situation with lower stakes
then spread of
actressly a remedy in her memoirs
recalls visiting crews at his home and
watching him lose it over cookie
ingredients
yelling at his assistant goddammit can i
get the stuff
for the cookie guys get the [ __ ] pre
okay so
um i'm very exhausted of keeping my
distance from but cruz
who's also not wrong thanks to the
thanks the way the relief has worked has
currently in the terrible situation in
which
the grocery budgets and college savings
accounts of many people rest on cruises
points out mission impossible
continue to film the situation sucks but
that's what it is
hey shannon by the way you [ __ ] dumb
if it was tom cruise yelling at women
this week can you cause these are men by
the way these are two men that were
standing to close each other
if tom cruise in a position of power
because did remember the me too [ __ ]
was yelling at women this way for not
doing it or
yelling at a black woman this way for
not doing her job
do you think the story would be
different because all i kept hearing
during the [ __ ]
louis ck thing and the harvey weinstein
thing is these men who were positions of
power
and they were using their power
hollywood's not that [ __ ] important
you know why i don't care about this
i understand that a lot of people have
jobs because this movie's going on
but hollywood got these exemptions
from the california because they're
filming california too
they got these exemptions for these
downs not small businesses
not [ __ ] restaurants not mom and pop
shops
hollywood did the people that actually
provide more jobs than holly
than these [ __ ] hollywood people do
so my heart doesn't [ __ ] bleed for
these people i don't care
because once this movie shuts down these
people go back they're not having a job
again
so oh sorry and like you brought up too
it's like you guys are always so
concerned about the
you know men taking advantage of power
imbalances so that they can assert their
you know dominance and it's like what do
you think tom cruise is doing here he's
like five foot one
yeah so do you think he's yelling do you
think a guy and i'm not even
exaggerating it's not like an owen
benjamin punchline he's like 5-1 like
tom cruise is a small man
and do you think a guy tom cruise's size
is going to get away with talking to
people like that if he's not tom cruise
somebody could [ __ ] throw him down a
laundry shoot
and he'd be gone forever so yeah it's
it's it's [ __ ] up man
and again i already pointed out this
whole thing could have just been handled
the way i just did it earlier and no
there'd be no
you see you could you can still address
a problem
and then bring it up you know like don't
get me wrong i when i when i used to
manage and stuff
but like i have lost it like that on the
staff
i have but like it has to be like
that there's there's already been three
or four of the presentations i just did
like earlier where it's like hey guys
can you come here
listen please we got to really be better
about this
if we're not we're going to get [ __ ]
by the health department this is going
to happen that's going to happen
i really need you to work with me
because honestly i don't want to fire
anybody
but if you're not doing what you're
being paid for here i may have to find
somebody else
then you get to a point where if it's
like the sixth time you
might there there could be footage of me
acting like this
but it's like by that point you're like
but he's just a psycho hollywood dude
huh
little five foot two [ __ ] tough guy
they were standing too close by a
computer that's all they did
you the way he's acting you would think
they were licking each other's eyeballs
i swear to god
and i can't deal with your logic you're
fired that's it
that is it
i trust you guys to be here
that's it
hey tom weren't you the one that
basically had katie holmes like in
prison in her own home where she
couldn't leave dude that was some wild
[ __ ] man you ever hear some of them
stories oh yeah yeah no
[ __ ] crazy by the way it's as much as
i i don't adam really like leah remedy i
think she's nuts
but some of the stories you hear about
cruz and scientology and all they say
you don't [ __ ] have this [ __ ]
right to yell at people like this
jesus christ yeah dude these are some
really [ __ ] up
individuals and i think and i think
we've always all kind of known and
suspected especially with tom cruise
that he's a
he's a whack job and all these
scientologist people are whack jobs
[ __ ] gross man there's just no way to
handle that situation again
there's even a way to even if you're
gonna yell a little bit there's a way to
do it but that was just full on sight
like that was
psychotic but who but again you're right
but who
[ __ ] like the my thing is
how important these people think they
are you know
how how important these hollywood people
really think they are how they really
think they're sucking saving lives no
they're not none of you are none of that
[ __ ] important
well not just hollywood but you know tom
cruise has the added layer of the
being the god of scientology which
doesn't i'm sure it doesn't help tempers
ego